mieux de mieux c'est d'être amoureux de
s'aimer comme en français ça alors bon
si après on va se faire des chiens
j'ai fait des missions sur la de Tina
kayfer là sur la pollution atmosphérique
par les bagnoles en ville et tout ça et
puis il y a un truc que j'ai oublié de
dire et depuis hier soir je m'en veux je
veux plus dire à toi du coup c'est que
en plus je trouve ça tellement c'est
tellement la France il y a un gus as-tu
à Toulouse vous êtes qui est inventeur
français moyen-atto Camille au poids une
plaque pour les voitures électriques
ultra légère tu vois je sais pas c'est
des batteries des histoires de batterie
il a réussi à faire sa plat léger et
tout et ben aucun constructeur français
n'en a voulu
à la télé il a vendu au japonais et j'ai
oublié de dire ça à la télé et vraiment
je suis folle d'orage parce qu'il y
avait tous les gus avec lui dire ça tu
vois tu t'es rattrapé à la tienne j'ai
un esprit d'escalier comment ça va ça va
bien je m'amuse bien tu es allé à Malte
finalement ouais je suis allée à Malte
Noël tu veux bien mais on peut se
changer
vous travaillez ensemble oui tu sais que
j'ai donné son premier travail hein
il m'a fait chier tout le repas de midi
avec ce long
mais qu'est-ce que tu veux
de la pub et après il a fait les palmes
de Monsieur Schulz et là il est devenu
beaucoup d'argent non ouais
10 millions de francs mais en fait c'est
il y a 10000 enfants qui me sont passés
entre les mains qui ont donné lieu à des
recettes qui mettaient dû et là-dessus
après il y a Jean 10% et ça c'est des 10
% et puis un pont pas loin 60% donc en
fait je retrouvais avec un peu moins de
entre trois et quatre briques et comme
tu te crois super riche tu vis au-dessus
de tes moyens et le résultat quand même
aux girolles s'il vous plaît voilà vu
c'est Pascal est super sympa et c'est le
plan du Cantal ici je comprends pas que
vous avez choisi ce théâtre
et un endroit où on nous fait pas chier
différentes possibilités à trois donc de
garçons et de filles que tu vois comme
sur un vase grec j'ai une chose un peu
comme culturel et là pour l'instant mes
camarades me font offrent donc ils le
sentent pas de sa chimie
tout ça pour vous dire que donc c'est
quand même principalement moi ce que
j'aime c'est faire dans ce genre de de
circonstances en fait ce qui m'intéresse
aussi le jeu d'acteur moi quand je veux
dire
le jeu d'acteurs
ça m'énerve parce que il bavarde plus
que moi
il arrive à bavarder plus plus plus
longtemps et plus fort que moi c'est
exact
mais pas revenir à Balzac
lui commence comme ça c'est quand on
pense aux relations de l'homme et de la
femme depuis le néandertalien etc et
bien on se rend compte qu'en France même
etc et en France si l'on prend ce coin
de Bretagne qui est la Bretagne ouest
Sud etc et qu'on arrive jusqu'au village
qui se termine par et dans la chaumière
à la maison la rue la machin dans le
fauteuil se trouve se nomme le vieillard
et sur le front de ce noble vieillard
l'observateur attentif pourrait lire que
et hop c'est parti pour la biographie du
nobles vieillard ah non 70
de la soupe à l'oignon avec des sushis
c'est à dire là ils sont en train de
faire un repas il y en a qui sont en
train de faire quand même c'est un repas
auvergnat japonais c'est pas mal hein
moi j'essaye de essayer avec la blague
de girolles et les sushis c'est pas
[Musique]
je parle de fumer des cigarettes
c'est complètement rodé
dans un premier temps c'est pas une très
bonne idée
en fait
je ne sais pas ce que tu trouves cette
soupe à l'oignon elle a préféré des
délicieux sushia
[Musique]
d'abord et ensuite voilà
moi c'est un truc qui me fascine
toujours c'est l'inventivité humaine
pour les les jouets du plaisir disons un
plan salé du plaisir c'est à dire que
l'autre jour on va dans un endroit une
famille d'abord le godemichet lumineux
c'est à dire le godemichet pour les
partouzes pour plus perdre ton vieux
ensuite pour les gens qui adorent le
film King ils avaient le good mission en
forme de points et pour les filles qui
aiment les pieds c'est des filles
paraît-il qui prennent leur pied mais
qui prennent aussi des pieds ils avaient
ils le godemichet en forme de pied et il
y a détruit
donc pour la première fois de ma vie
j'ai pu enfin aller dans un sex shop
parce que tu vois le côté tu es dans une
ça va salut gênant c'est le drame de la
notoriété ça arrive dans un bar à [ __ ]
il demande des nouvelles de tes enfants
et donc enfin votre propriété j'ai pu
faire la visite
mais alors comme entre-temps j'en avais
été réduite au bouquin bibliothèque au
musée pour me regarder quand même sur
les choses de la vie
j'ai trouvé ça nettement moins bien
non calibre sur la sexualité des Chinois
que j'avais lu à Taïwan comme le
conseiller culturel m'avait refilé ou
quand même je trouve que les accessoires
chinois par exemple ils avaient pour le
garçon un petit disque qu'on s'enfile
comme ça sur la sur la quéquette et qui
est en jade et alors le dragon vachement
bien sculpter paraît-il très agréable
pour la dame hein et j'ai acheté aussi à
Taïwan une petite noix avec des
spécialités rares où nous avons c'est
sculpté une nouvelle loi qui est entière
avec sa noix de dents et toute vernis
sculpter finement comme pour les Chinois
et nous avons la petite dame avec à la
seconde comme les danseuses indiennes
assises vous ce qui est déjà il faut
être très souple le garçon qui est monté
sur sa cuisse et qui tente de l'allure
filet de l'oreille mais oui mais oui
une façon de raconter une civilisation
une société extraordinaire ce que tu
vois c'est tu vas en bout ou tu vas même
ici dans des engins toujours plus gros
avec des moteurs avec des lumières
Mercedes voilà
il s'appelle je crois érotique à
universaliste je sais pas si tu connais
ça commence à l'Antiquité grecque avec
les vases etc le moyen-âge on arrive à
l'époque moderne on va tout en compte
à travers les âges
c'est du temps des Grecs en gros il y
avait c'était assez simple quand il y
avait les maîtres les filles les chèvres
bon et là on avait besoin ensuite
commence
les parties
une compilation de tous les textes des
moches ils parlent de la mésopotamiens
il y a 45 chiens qui s'appelait Guy
Lamesch qui dit le matin entre le vent
tu te tapes une
vachement
le 18e
la date de la Révolution française c'est
bien ce que je pense non pas du tout
Tibère les enfants Romains
de la lettre et et sadomaso de façon
César et donc ils ne savent pas mais
c'est le cas ah bah oui oui mais le côté
corset
fustiger et à baiser ensemble il faisait
des tableaux érotiques dans son jardin à
Capri
île de Capri contemporain du Christ
était l'empereur pendant que le Christ
était Christ et dans un Capri son île
son fief il leur est le soir il fallait
qu'il y ait dans les jardins des groupes
humains en train de faire des faits
alors on va utiliser le les termes genre
fond vert justement des fellations des
sodomie et des accouplements de toutes
sortes avec des animaux etc et il devait
être pile en pleine forme et en pleine
action quand le quand Tibère se
promenait dans son jardin c'est du
cinéma porno et en même temps il était
d'une cruauté terrible et il les
envoyait à partir du moment où tu
organises des partouze d'une part et qui
n'est quand que tu jettes des gens sur
les rochers
alors bon c'est après on va se faire des
jeux
m'avait dit donc je peux pas le garder
pour moi maintenant il faut que je le
dise il m'a dit vraiment
pour se chier dessus on se met très fort
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu